TGIF.
I'm going casual Friday.
Oh yeah!
Oh, you guys, it's so nice to see all our VFFs
and by the way, hi, everybody!
Your signs are always so amazing
and it just means the world to us that you are here
and I will be your BFF anytime, I'm here right now
and it's funny 'cause I woke up this morning,
I looked around and I always am worried
my alarm is gonna wake up my two daughters,
'cause they were sleeping with me
and my alarm went off and I looked around
and I had my two daughters and then our cat, Lucky,
our cat, Peach, Lucy and Douglas
and there was just,
it looked like we were sleeping in Noah's Ark
and it was the most cozy, beautiful moment
and I felt so lucky.
My first kids really were my animals and now I have kids,
so, you know, the pets come second, but they're family
and I just, I love getting to be with my daughters
and our pets, so when I heard about all the work
of one of our VFFs today, Kelly Donley, was doing
to make sure that families and their pets
stayed together during the pandemic,
I really wanted to meet her, so Kelly, are you there?
Yeah!
Hi, Kelly, how are you?
(clearing throat)
Excuse me.
Speaking of pets.
(coughing)
I have a frog in my throat.
Oh my gosh. I do too,
because I'm just so excited to meet you.
Thank you!
Oh, I'm so glad you're here and when I heard your story,
I just thought, okay,
I wanted to tell the story of my morning
because our pets are so important to us
and you started a food pantry for pets out of your garage,
so that people could take care of their animals.
I mean, what gave you the idea to do that?
Yeah, so I've been a rescuer for a long time,
a solid rescuer since 2012, I love animals
and I know that that's always an issue,
needing pet food and needing care and so with the pandemic,
I just knew things were that much worse.
I was hearing so many stories of individuals
having to surrender their pets
due to not being able to feed them
and, you know, that's heart-wrenching.
They're like our children, right?
You know, you just talked about all your babies
in your bed with you and your kids
and that's heartbreaking.
I feel like during such trying times,
that's the last thing that a family needs,
is to have to surrender their pet,
so I just decided to take to Facebook
and see if there was any way that I could help
local families in need.
And what responses did you get?
Oh my gosh, Drew, it was so crazy.
On both sides of the coin,
there were so many, so many individuals that wanted to help.
I couldn't believe how many folks were offering
to send and bring food and then on top of that,
I actually set some days where I would actually go out
into the community and help folks
who didn't have transportation,
who couldn't come pick up the food and Drew,
that was actually the hardest part for me
because when I put out a post asking, you know,
"Hey, if you aren't able to get to me, but I can deliver,"
I got some of the saddest stories, you know?
I would end up in places
that you could really tell that the need was, yeah.
I mean, Kelly, we want to continue to help you
spread the love,
so we reached out to our friends at Petco
and I'm such a Petco fan.
So because of you, they wanna give you $5000 for vet bills
and another $5000 for pet food.
Yes!
Thank you, Petco!
Thank you so much.
I can't even begin to tell you, the vet bills too!
That's something else we've been trying so hard to work on.
That is so huge!
Well, you inspired us to think differently
and the fact that you are thinking differently
is just such a great benefit
to creatures on four and two legs
and so thank you for all that you are doing.
Thank you, I did not expect that!
That is so awesome!
Thank you.
I can't wait to see you do more
and we'll keep in touch and see how it's all going.
Thank you.
Yay, yay!
(upbeat music)